مع انتهاء العميل حاليا عد مكتب الامم
المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون الانسانيه تقديراته
لاحتياجات سكان العالم في العام المقبل
ليتضح ان واحده وعشرين مليون و600 الف سنه
سيحتاجون الى المساعده في انخفاض بنحو
مليون و 800 الف شخص عن العام الحالي
تراجع عن ترافق مع انخفاض حده العنف في
الصراع اليمني المستمر منذ اكثر من ثمان
سنوات وعلى الرغم من تناقص عدد المحتاجين
للمساعده لكن الارقام تبقى كبيره في هذا
البلد الذي يبلغ عدد سكانه 32 مليون نسمه
التقرير تطرق ايضا الى القضايا الاساسيه
التي تؤثر على حياتي اليمنيين فالمتفجرات
التي خلفتها الحرب منتشره وتشكل تهديدا
مباشره على السكان تحيق حركتهم وتتسبب
بوفاه او باصابه عشرات الاشخاص شهريا
الامر الاخر يتعلق بالفيضانات الموسميه
التي قد تتكرر وتؤدي الى نزوح السكان
وتعطيل سور عيشهم وزياده الامراض المنقوله
بالمياه فض يعني اتلاف المحاصيل وتدمير
الممتلكات ففي العام الحالي تاثرت
بالفيضانات
74,سره معظمها تعيش في مواقع النزوح لذا
تقول الامم المتحده لابد من تعلم الدروس
من السنوات السابقه وتشدد على ضروره ايجاد
حلول مستدامه لايواء النازحين في اليمن